aquarelle acrylique pastel jeune mercy a
plusieurs cordes à son arc
ici l'artiste yvelinoise laisse libre
cours à son imagination
elle aime jongler parmi les genres en
dessinant autant les animaux que les
portraits ou encore les paysages dans le
paysage on est plus libre de 2 comment
dire de ne pas faire les choses
exactement comme il faut bien symétrique
bien alors que quand je fais des animaux
c'est pour trouve pour retrouver un peu
de rigueur que que j'aime bien en fait
tous plus portrait l'artiste trouve son
inspiration dans ses photos de voyages
prise au cours du temps elle modifie
ensuite ces clichés au gré de saison 10
j'ai pris en photo il ya une quinzaine
d'années quand j'étais au château de
versailles donc tu fous j'ai ressorti
ses petits clins d'oeil à l'inspiration
j'ai toujours c'est juste ça dépend des
moments donc si aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de peindre je sais pas il pleure parce
que j'ai vu que le feu tombent plaisait
pas je peux la faire aujourd'hui mais
demain ce sera pas qu'à jade merci n'est
pas tombé dans l'art par hasard elle
découvre qu'elle est atteinte d'une
maladie il y a une dizaine d'années
l'art devient alors un moyen de s'évader
de s'exprimer près j'ai bifurqué dans
l'art en attendant d'être greffés après
j'ai fait je suis pas deux ans après
j'ai déjà un temps pour la convalescence
est histoire de commun dire de me
sociabiliser j'ai j'ai fait d'atelier en
atelier a fait toutes sortes d'activités
j'ai pratiqué un peu tout ça et le
pastel c'est tombé c'est tombé comme ça
une exposition des tableaux d'eugène
merci est en cours à magny les hameaux
avec la crise sanitaire et les mesures
en vigueur l'exposition a été adapté
elle est visible jusqu'au dimanche 7
février au travers des vitres de la
mairie de l'estaminet et du centre
social